apple hat gestern in Indien seinen
ersten
eröffnet was bedeutet das für Indien
also Tim Kock Tim guckt der der Mann
hier sieht der Chef von Apple war da und
Apple überlegt natürlich jetzt
strategisch nachdem sehr viel Fertigung
der iPhones die wir alle so lieben in
China oder in Taiwan stattfindet das
jetzt so langsam nach Indien zu holen
also insofern ist das ein strategischer
Schritt in der zweite hängt ein bisschen
mit der Zahl zusammen die du genannt
hast 1,4 Milliarden potentielle Käufer
also das ist ein Riesenmarkt wenn du das
gerade ansprichst ist interessant ne 90
% der iPhone Fertigung findet immer noch
in China statt Fox das Stichwort aber 6%
immerhin auch schon in Indien sind 13
Millionen Geräte das heißt welche
Bedeutung hat Apple dieser der führende
Konzern auf dem Planeten welche
Bedeutung hat der für ein Land wie
Indien
ich weiß nicht ob die Fertigung von
Mobiltelefonen am Ende
Indiens Stärke werden wird also das ist
manchmal glaube ich so ein bisschen eine
vieleinschätzung dass man denkt das was
in China ging geht jetzt auch in Indien
ich glaube das ist nicht so die indische
Kultur ist anders
sie ist glaube ich sehr kreativ sie ist
sehr theoretisch in der großartige
Mathematiker tolle it äh Leute
Programmierer aber die Fertigung in
Indien ist immer so ein bisschen
kritisch ich meine kreativ war das die
Übersetzung für chaotisch auch so ein
bisschen würde man je nach Kultur
vielleicht so nennen ich habe so einen
schönen Satz von dir du sagst wenn 100
Kinder zusammen kommen und eine Sache
machen sollen Ende des im Chaos genau es
endet nicht nur im Chaos sondern wenn
man noch effektivitätswerte dran setzt
wenn man sagen also wenn 100 deutsche
zusammen kommen und jeder hat sozusagen
Leistung 1 dann ist in den deutschen so
dass das sich summiert und mehr als 100
ist weil die kann das bei den Chinesen
ist es vielleicht 200 bei den Kindern
ist es dann vielleicht nur zehn weil die
sich gegenseitig ja die Show stehen es
zeigt natürlich die Öffnung ist ja nicht
so dass es vorher keine Apple Produkte
in Indien gegeben hat ne aber es zeigt
natürlich jeder drin ist das zeigt
inzwischen dass es genügend Leute gibt
weil Inder sind sehr preissensitiv und
wir wissen alle dass Apple teuer ist das
heißt das zeigt natürlich dass es jetzt
doch inzwischen so viele Leute die dort
dass es sich lohnt für Apple dort auch
größer einzusteigen auch mit dem Store
nee
ich habe das eingangs gesagt wir reden
hier wirklich über so einen riesen der
da gerade erwacht und der die Tektonik
in der Welt auch noch mal verschiebt und
es fällt ja auch wenn man wenn man
gleich ein paar Bilder auch sehen es
fällt ja auf wer sich dort in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten alles die
Klinke in die Hand gegeben hat also
plötzlich finden alle Indien ganz knorke
von Olaf Scholz bis macron bis alle
geben sich dort plötzlich die Linke in
die Hand warum
der Grund hat meines Erachtens mit drei
Dingen zu tun das erste ist global
politisch
knistert ein Konflikt der sich immer
mehr verstärkt zwischen den USA und
China und irgendwie will man sich jetzt
in Stellung bringen und ein großes
Bestreben ist zum Beispiel von Seiten
der Amerikaner aber indirekt eben auch
ein bisschen von Seiten von Herrn Scholz
zu sagen komm auf unsere Seite und das
ist ein Missverständnis weil Indien
immer blockfrei war weil Indien immer
ein Land war was nie gesagt hat pro
Amerika oder pro damals Sowjetunion
sondern mehr dort auch in den ganz
vielen verschiedenen associations in den
ist drin ist immer in der Politik weil
es neutral in der oder unabhängig
bleiben möchte ist der erste Punkt der
zweite ist
hängt ein bisschen mit dem
Bevölkerungswachstum zusammen die OECD
sagt im Jahr 2030 werden
37% aller Ingenieure aus China kommen
und 27% aus Indien im Vergleich
Deutschland 1,8% Wahnsinn heißt in
anderen Worten schon heute Ingenieure
darüber reden wir reden über auch
Software-Ingenieure aber nicht nur und
was man eben merkt ist wir haben bei uns
das Riesenproblem Fachkräftemangel und
hier hast du eine Nation mit klugen
Leuten wo man natürlich so langsam
überlegt okay wenn die für uns arbeiten
dann geht's unserem Business immer noch
gut wenn wir keinen
Fachkräfte finden dann irgendwie ein
Problem noch mal ganz kurz bevor wir ein
paar Bilder sehen Frau Petersen dieser
riesige Markt das war ja auch die große
Versuchung und auch die Verführung immer
für die deutsche Wirtschaft dieser
riesige chinesische Markt weil kann man
hier mit mit CE ausspricht von großen
deutschen Unternehmen und und sie darauf
anspricht und sagt also China da müssen
wir doch ein bisschen vorsichtig jetzt
sein und und aufpassen dass wir nicht so
wahnsinnig abhängig werden dann sagen
die dir knüppelhart ins Gesicht was sind
sie für ein naiver Mensch wie können Sie
ernsthaft glauben dass man auf diesen
gigantischen Markt von 1,3 Milliarden
einfach so verzichten kann dann ist der
deutsche Wohlstand hinüber was heißt das
1,4 Milliarden in Bezug auf Indien nicht
alle diese 1,4 Milliarden sind ja in der
Lage neues iPhone zu kaufen also
westliche Produkte zu kaufen über
welchen Markt reden wir denn wirklich ja
der Markt ist doch inzwischen sehr groß
ne also ähm die konservativen
Schätzungen gehen davon aus dass die
Mittelklasse in Indien zwischen 350
Millionen Menschen sind und es gibt es
gibt andere Schätzungen die noch
sozusagen die untere Mittelklasse mit
einbeziehen und da sind 600 Millionen
Menschen aber das heißt das ist einmal
EU noch mehr
mit ohne brexit also das ist schon auch
ein ein gigantischer Markt der bisher
natürlich noch überhaupt nicht in dem
Maße barcart wurde wie China und die
deutsche Außenministerin ist ja nun
gerade in China gewesen und und will ja
gerne von China weggehen allerdings ist
sie natürlich nicht die Entscheidung
darüber trifft was die deutsche
Industrie tut aber ähm das ist natürlich
Indien ist der einzige große die einzige
große Alternative zu China wenn man
wirklich sagen möchte man möchte das
Risiko diversifizieren
ich habe ein zweiter Aspekt ist
nach 400 Jahren Kolonialisierung nach
400 Jahren auch sage ich mal Demütigung
das hat man in China gesehen das ist
eine Wunde das hat man in Indien gesehen
gibt es jetzt sozusagen eine Phase
glaube ich auch das Erwachens auch des
Selbstbewusstseins wir haben ja ein
Problem mit China ein bisschen auch
dadurch dass die Chinesen inzwischen
auch
selbstbewusst sagen hey wir wissen was
wir können wir sind in vielen Bereichen
ja Weltspitze und wir lassen uns nicht
mehr rumkommandieren wie das noch vor 50
100 oder 200 Jahren der Fall war in
Indien fängt das jetzt allmählich auch
an ein bisschen langsamer als in China
und die tiefere Frage ist natürlich sind
wir vorbereitet auf eine Welt bei der
wir auf der einen Seite sagen 1,3
Milliarden in China 1,4 Milliarden in
Indien
das werden die Zentren der auch Ökonomie
der Zukunft werden aber wir Europäer
laufen natürlich immer noch mit dem
alten narrativ wir sind der Nabel der
Welt die USA natürlich ja zähle ich
jetzt mal in dem in der Weltsicht ein
bisschen zu Europa dazu und merken gar
nicht da gibt es was ganz anderes was
allmählich auch hochkommt also wenn man
es provokant ausdrückt ich mache das
jetzt mal hier in deiner Sendung wir
haben den Längengrad der geht momentan
durch Greenwich also der Nullmeridian
vorher ging er durch Madeira oder durch
Paris und eigentlich müssten wir sagen
also wir gehen immer durch die Nationen
die das Sagen hatten vielleicht ist es
jetzt an der Zeit zu sagen Danke
was ist diese indische Wirtschaft heute
also was was macht dafür ein großer
neuer Player worin sind die stark was
haben die für Rohstoffe wo er wächst da
eine neue Konkurrenzsituation
das ist ja sozusagen Entwicklung die
schon seit längerem stattfindet neben
der IT-Industrie ist es Indien bekannt
als Apotheker der Welt in Indien werden
wird der Großteil aller Generika für den
für den weltweiten Markt hergestellt
haben
von teuren von teuren Medikamenten genau
die günstige Version sozusagen davon ja
genau
Impfstoffe ganz großes Thema ja jetzt
gerade gewesen ne ähm
Indien produziert aber auch und das muss
man sich immer vor Augen führen das ist
ein Markt der der ist an sich schon so
groß dass Indien für seinen eigenen
Markt auch viel produziert und das nimmt
jetzt unter Modi noch mal wieder stärker
zu dass
man schaut stärker auf den eigenen Markt
man will dass
in Indien produziert wird die ganze
make-in ja Kampagne die damals gestartet
hat
das ist aber tatsächlich jetzt nicht
erst seit gestern sondern im Prinzip
schon seit Mondi an die an die Macht kam
dass er die indische Regierung versuchen
will
Produktion nach Indien zu verlagern auch
zum Beispiel gerade weil wir hier die
Bilder von von macron gesehen haben im
Rüstungsbereich Indien möchte sich sehr
stark unabhängig machen im
Rüstungsbereich natürlich auch
unabhängig von Russland
bisher kommen die Hälfte der
Rüstungsgüter aus aus Russland aber die
Russen die Waffen bedauerlicherweise
selber brauchen
fällt und deswegen ist Frankreich
inzwischen der zweitgrößte Lieferant von
Rüstungsgüter nach Indien und ist eben
auch bereit bestimmte Teile dafür dann
in Indien zu produzieren ne
wieder gerade sehen Modi haben sie
gerade angesprochen ne der ist irre
beliebt in Indien habe ich teilweise ja
teilweise ja genau kommt drauf an wenn
man fragt warum ist das so wo woraus
bezieht er seine Glaubwürdigkeit dass
die Geschichte dieses Mannes ja das ist
tatsächlich eine sehr interessante
Geschichte weil der Modi steht
exemplarisch für die den Aufstiegswillen
der der unteren Teil der Bevölkerung er
ist der erste Premierministerin der
wirklich aus der der arbeiterkaste kommt
der sein Vater hat einen Teeladen gehabt
und Straßen ganz ganz kleine
Herkunft werden alle anderen
Premierminister immer aus aus der Elite
gekommen sind
er ist selber er hat sich nach oben
gearbeitet es wahnsinnig ehrgeizig
wahnsinnig diszipliniert und
verkörpert damit dieses Versprechen ja
das können wir doch auch schaffen hier
ja
ist seit zwei 14 2014 ist er und macht
und macht dort was es gibt ja verrückte
Videos auch damit man kann dem zugucken
bei meditieren und stundenlang ich
glaube das sind wichtiger Punkt weil er
drauf gekommen dass das wichtig ist aber
es scheint zu sein es gibt darum ähm
peter hat das ein bisschen angesprochen
frühere Lieder kamen immer aus dieser
elitären Schicht jetzt kommt einer
wirklich aus dem ich sag mal voll man
muss immer klar machen jede Nation auch
Indien hat natürlich eine sehr starke
Bindung an Religion oder an Religiosität
und das ist natürlich der Kit mit dem
man auch viele gewinnt
und das hat er sehr stark forciert also
er ist einer der natürlich die die sich
Hindu wo Visionen da nach oben hält also
man muss nur weit genug in der
Geschichte zurückgehen dann war ihnen
den ein Land von Hindus ist natürlich
immer fragwürdig wenn
Politiker weit zurückgehen will jemand
vorsichtig ne tun ja auch Leute wie
Putin auch gerne weiter zurück aber das
kritische daran ist dass damit im Grunde
genommen diese säkulare Struktur
plötzlich aufbricht also und das was in
ihnen gefährlich ist ist in den Stand
immer für eine große Toleranz an der
Stelle und das wird eingeengt durch eine
Partei die immer mehr sozusagen man
würde hier schon fast sagen manchmal ein
bisschen fanatisch ist wenn man
nationalistisch nationalistisch ist wenn
man Mut die betrachtet was er vorher
gemacht hat bevor er premier wurde war
er Chef in gute Rat das ist ein
Bundesstaat im westenindiens und da
merkte man schon dieser alte Konflikt
hindurch gegen Moslems den feitet er
durch und das sehen natürlich viele
kritisch würde ich sagen das ist ein
Präsident der auch oder an
Premierminister der spaltet und das ist
natürlich für ein so großes Land nicht
gut so interessant nur spricht in der
Öffentlichkeit nie Englisch obwohl er
glaube ich sehr gut englisch spricht
nein sehr gut für dich
okay
aber tatsächlich weil das zu der eigenen
Community spricht nicht ja und dieses
Verhältnis zu Russland was was ist das
für ein Verhältnis war ja interessant zu
sehen und auch diese Ratlosigkeit zu
sehen also
einerseits diese Konfrontation speziell
von Seiten der Amerikaner mit China das
uns allen als Europäern gemacht und dann
der versucht sozusagen die in der dann
wenigstens auf unsere Seite zu ziehen
funktioniert aber nicht enthalten sich
im Sicherheitsrat sind nicht eindeutig
auf der Seite des Westens du sagst
diesen blockfreiheit zu tun aber ist es
das nur oder was ist ich meine wenn man
die beiden hier so sieht also sehr viel
inniger kann man sich nicht umarmen na
sag mal so ich denke dass das Verhältnis
zu Russland gar nicht mehr so eng ist
wie das mal gewesen ist als als das
beides sozusagen sozialistische Ländern
hat was aber entscheidend ist zu
verstehen ist das Indien kein Interesse
daran hat dass Russland zu einem
geschwächten Wurmfortsatz von China wird
Indien möchte
geostrategisch gesehen eine multipolare
Weltordnung die regelbasiert ist und in
dieser multipularen Weltordnung spielt
Indien spielt China spielen die USA
spielen Europa natürlich aber auch die
Afrikanische Union der Merkur die Asien
ähm eine Rolle und die Idee dahinter ist
und das geht dann tatsächlich auf diese
Blockfreien Bewegung zurück dass man man
möchte einfach aufgrund der
Kolonialgeschichte nicht mehr zum
Anhänger von
wieder den USA oder den oder
irgendjemanden werden und je größer die
sozusagen der Strauß der Mächte ist die
weltpolitisch agieren umso eher sieht
Indien sich in der Rolle wo es selber
eben Herr seines Schicksals ist und wenn
du dieses Bild zeigst könntest du direkt
daneben ein Bild zeigen wo nur die Trump
umarmt mit derselben Ähnlichkeit oder
macron oder
ich weiß ich habe jetzt kein Bild vor
Augen ich weiß nicht ob man Scholz so
anders
man merkt ihm damit das ist äh eine
Haltung bei der dieses
bipolare denken bei dem wir glaube ich
hier ein bisschen in der Falle tapsen zu
sagen es gibt entweder nur gute
Hamburger das ist eine Hamburger
Umarmung also aber es geht ihm darum zu
verstehen dieses Land lässt sich nicht
die Zeit wo man was alle war wo man ja
die ist vorbei für ihn genauso wie für
China und ich glaube an der Stelle täte
der auch der Westen gut eine neue
Perspektive auf diese Länder zu haben
und nicht wie in alten Kategorien sehr
opportun zu überlegen was kann ich jetzt
mit dem machen oder wie kann ich den
irgendwo zur Seite ziehen oder gar
politisch eingreifen soll zu verstehen
nein die Welt wird an der glaube ich
wirklich anders wie wird sie anders Frau
Petersen das ist ja sehr interessant
wenn du plötzlich nicht mehr sozusagen
diese beiden Blöcke hast ne wie zur Zeit
des Kalten Krieges sondern plötzlich
macht jeder so sein Zeug multipolar wie
sie sagen was bedeutet das auch für uns
aus deutscher Sicht ich glaube also die
Entscheidung ist ja jetzt noch gar nicht
gefallen es hängt ja sehr viel davon ab
wie der Ukraine Krieg ausgeht welche
welche Positionen wird Russland nach
diesem Krieg einnehmen
in der Vorstellung der Inder denke ich
ist das eine Win-Win-Situation
über die wir uns auch in Deutschland
möglicherweise mehr Gedanken machen
müssen macron hat ja nur gerade eine
große Kontroverse von vom Zaun gebrochen
wobei diese Position die ja da vertreten
hat er gesagt irgendwie wir müssen als
Europäer und uns unabhängige von den USA
machen ja wir wollen nicht mehr Amerika
sein ja genau das ist im Prinzip ja auch
nichts neues das das
auch schon formuliert und und macron
auch ja immer wieder
das deckt sich im Grunde genommen auch
mit der Weltsicht der Inder und und ich
denke das auch aus dem Grund tatsächlich
Frankreich möglicherweise unter den
europäischen Nationen und mir das Ängste
Verhältnis hat zu Indien weil ich
Franzosen wollen das auch die wollen das
Europa hat einen eigenständiger rapool
wird ich habe die Deutschen wollen es
auch nicht so offiziell aber wenn man
wirklich mal da drunter guckt wie die
Beziehungen sind zur Wirtschaft und so
weiter dann ist das auch da aber ich
glaube der der entscheidende Punkt ist
das ist weniger ein Problem Indiens es
ist mehr vielleicht eine Lektion für uns
also an irgendeiner Stelle mal
aufzuwachen zu sagen die Welt ändert
sich und auch unsere Rolle wird
vielleicht nicht mehr die sein zu sagen
we are the greatest ja das ist die große
gefallen Moment dass man manchmal denkt
die USA die natürlich eine große
Wirtschaftsmacht sind aber die in den
nächsten Jahren natürlich ganz einfach
quantitativ schon durch China oder
Indien er überflügelt werden können die
noch Platz zwei sind die bereit und wenn
die das nicht sind weil das oft fast
religiös ist Gotts Country und so weiter
dann wird es gefährlich und da glaube
ich sehr wichtig ein Weg rauszufinden
weil sonst enden wir in einem Konflikt
das ist bei kleinen Ländern ich meine
ich bin halber Inder und halber
Luxemburger die Luxemburger sind da sehr
praktisch weil die haben nie diese ja
hohen da kann man die Größe gar nicht so
wirklich entwickeln ja aber das zu
verstehen und das bedeutet an der Stelle
eine friedliche Welt die ein Mosaik ist
aber wo dieser alten Achsen vorbei sind
weil das das geht ist aber das ist ein
europäisches Denken was zurück geht in
die Anfänge der Kolonialisierung es gibt
den
Vertrag von Tor desias ja als die
Spanier und Portugiesen ja anfing da war
die Welt noch nicht mal bekannt und dann
hat man damals schon eine Linie gezogen
zogen und gesagt alles was westlich
davon ist kriegen die Spanier alles was
östlich ist die Portugiesen dass der
Grund warum in Brasilien heute noch
Portugiesisch ist genau alles andere ist
Spanisch also das ist aber so ein denken
wir teilen uns die Welt auf nein das
geht nicht mehr weil es gibt noch andere
und man muss den Kuchen vielleicht
anders aufteilen ich bin interessanten
Satz von dir gestolpert mich auch
interessieren was Frau Petersen dazu
sagt Indien war niematerialistisch
was heißt das ursprünglich war also
Indien hatte immer noch
eine andere Ebene man würde sagen etwas
spirituelles es war es hat sich nie
definiert nach mein Haus mein Boot mein
Pool das war sozusagen eine Grundhaltung
das war übrigens in vielen anderen
Ländern auch so das ist so in den
letzten Jahrzehnten sind wir immer
materieller geworden heute
betrachtet man Nationen nur unter der
ökonomischen Brille und ich glaube das
ist eine riesen Chance an der Stelle
auch zu verstehen es gibt noch eine
andere Dimension das ist ja gerade zu
der das andere Indien was unter der Tür
zu uns kommt also nicht in Form von
auf der Yogamatte auf der Yogamatte in
meinem spirituellen also wieder und so
weiter also weil wir natürlich als
materielle oder auf zu materielle
westliche Kulturen verstehen da fehlt
etwas Essentielles und das gibt es in
Indien immer noch das ist auch ein Land
bei dem die Vergangenheit nie völlig
abgestreift wurde also heute
die Einweihung von einem großen
computerzentrum und da gibt es das
Ritual ja mit truger mit allem drum und
dran also wer hier undenkbar ist in
Indien normal
und da holte der Modi natürlich auch
ganz viele Leute da da ab ich meine das
ist ja man muss sehr leicht sich mal
darüber lustig zu machen aber das ist ja
auch eine tolle Sache dass ich so ein
Premierminister da hinsetzt und
meditiert und den internationalen
yoga-tag irgendwie durchsetzt bei den
Vereinten Nationen aber ganz viele für
ganz viele Inder ist das ein Teil ihres
Lebens dass sie dass sie mit meditieren
dass sie nach Befreiung Streben das ist
ja eine Religion in der jeder nach
Befreiung gestrickt ja und das ist ja
das ist ja der das sozusagen die die
andere Dimension dahinter ein gewisser
Weise auch die Abkehr von Amerika ne
weil Amerika steht doch genau dafür es
geht um Geld es geht um ökonomischen
Erfolg es geht um die Frage von Zahlen
und das ist der Gegenentwurf das aber
möglicherweise würde ein Indian nicht
sagen die Abkehr im Sinne von der
Ausgrenzung sondern vielleicht den
Amerikaner auch da mitnehmen erinnern
wir uns die Zeit des woodstocks die Zeit
der Beatles wo Indien und wo diese ganze
ich sag mal indische Mystik und so
weiter ne große Rolle spielte also es
ist eher ein ja killing new software
also nicht so sehr reinmarschieren aber
merken es gibt noch eine andere
Dimension und es auch etwas was viele
Menschen die nach in den kommen sehr
schnell merken es ist manche es ist
chaotisch aber man merkt das schwingt
auch irgendetwas in diesem Land was
bedauerlicherweise hier nicht so da ist